in this latest bid to draw attention to
their plight around
300 migrants and their supporters have
set up camp here
right in front of paris historic hotel
de ville
they say they are fed up with inaction
on the part of the authorities to find a
solution
to their housing crisis
this is a problem of the french state
even the european problem perhaps there
is no european country that would really
like to receive refugees
we're here to demand shelter for all
those who remain on the street
most of families with children including
babies and accompanied minors from other
countries
they don't belong on the street many of
those
here are mothers with young children
after i got pregnant i called the
emergency services several times until i
gave birth
and then every week i was put somewhere
unstable always watching my children
outside
i am tired that's the reason i came
occupying public areas like this
has become a strategy employed by
groups like midi do me makeshift camps
like this
are set up and then are often brutally
cleared away by the authorities
the amount of force used in doing so has
come
under severe criticism
[Applause]
i
this year around 500 migrants were taken
in
by the state the authorities here in
paris have also apparently
called on the state for more action
fearful that the large-scale camps that
once plagued the city will return all of
this
comes of course as european union
leaders have
been meeting in brussels with migration
being a top issue for them the president
of the eu parliament says the current
situation
is scandalous
every time a boat arrives what happens
in brussels
the commission starts making phone calls
asking who can take 100 migrants
who can take 50 who can take miners in
i mean the situation how can it be
subject to this
volunteer-based mechanism it's
scandalous
but again there was no big breakthrough
and as the number of people trying to
reach europe is
on the rise again it seems that there
could soon be
even more arriving on european shores
and just like the people here finding
themselves
homeless charlotte dubinsky rt
paris